jusqu'à maintenant on disait chambord et
son château
désormais il faudra ajouter son château
et ses vignes car cinq cents ans après
leur introduction en val de loire des
ceps de romorantin ont été plantés sur
environ deux hectares des plants issus
d'un cépage historique des vignerons
marionnet c'est une vigne 100% française
à la différence des autres dans le monde
qui sont moitié française moitié
américaine et il y a un an on a voulu
multiplier ce patrimoine génétique hors
du commun
donc en plantant des vignes à chambord
on a fait des boutures de cette vieille
vigne qu'on a mis en pépinière pendant
un an
on a fait une sélection massale plan
datant d'avant 1840
ils sont donc antérieure à l'apparition
du phylloxéra la maladie dévastatrice de
la vigne et à ce titre nécessite une
attention particulière d'autant que les
futurs vendanges s'intégreront dans le
financement de domaine c'est un vrai
projet parce que nous plantons 12
hectares en deux ans pour avoir une
exploitation qui soit autonome et nous
allons utiliser ce revenu pour
entretenir le mur de chambord et les
bâtiments de chambord il y avait la
ligne ici nous revenons la vigne c'est
un visage de chambord qui a existé et
qu'on rétablisse planté en 2015 l'année
françois 1er la première vendange aura
lieu pour un autre adversaire
on se revoit en 2019 première récolte au
moment où on fêtera les 500 ans de la
construction de chambord quand tu es la
cuvée chambord ce sera un vin blanc sec
naturels et bio un vin de garde ce qui
est la moindre des choses quand on
côtoie l'histoire de france